welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
spoiling king and this video we're
breaking down the ending of the stand
it's been a rough and rocky road up
until now but we're finally at the end
and what has been a very strange finale
we're going to be breaking it all down
but if you've been following our
breakdowns for the last 9 weeks
i'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for
coverage on all the biggest
upcoming tv shows and movies now up top
i just want to talk about how this
episode was marketed as a brand new
ending for the stand that was four years
in the making
i'm sure many of you have been sticking
with the show through all its highs and
lows up until now to get to this point
and honestly i feel slightly
disappointed
i don't know if it's because i had some
preconceived notions that this would go
on to be something big and bombastic
that would answer
several questions about the ending of
the original work but all in all it
doesn't differ that heavily from the
eventual path that it takes
in the book franny and stu leave boulder
after the birth of her baby
because they realize that society is
starting to fall back into its bad
habits
in the complete and uncut edition flag
wakes up on a beach where he's greeted
by tribe members
and that's pretty much also how the
season ends too
so i feel like this being sold to us as
a brand new ending is slightly
misleading
but ryan herself does actually get a lot
more stuff to do
king stated that he felt like franny
never really got to make her own stand
and in many ways that is rectified by
this entry to varying degrees of success
we open with her baby being born and
quickly contracts captain trips
however the child recovers and it's not
too long before we realize that the
survivor's children
will inherit their immunity i feel that
because the baby abigail's father died
of trips
that it was susceptible however the
other baby that we see being born comes
from two parents that carried immunity
and thus it doesn't show any signs of
infection baby abigail is also the first
person who we know has recovered from
the disease
and this clearly shows signs of hope for
the future now the stand in general is
very much thought to be a metaphor for
rebirth
not only in the destruction and
reconstruction of society
but also in the mind states that people
have upon stu's return
fran realizes that the old ways are
starting to seep back into the city
and that people are once more becoming
divided over their beliefs
she can see the storm coming and doesn't
want their children to be affected in
this way
thus they return to her birthplace in
the country now one of the big issues
that i had with this episode
is its pacing i would have loved to have
seen the development of this negative
mind state in boulder
and france starting to realize that flag
was simply making people give into their
darkest desires
rather than being the person that caused
them we could have had an
in-depth psychological look at how
humans are flawed in a way that
eventually
makes us turn on one another but we're
simply just told by fran that things
will get bad
even though from what we see people are
still willing to help where they can
they also completely gloss over the
journey that stu and tom took together
along with the friendship that they
formed this would have been fine
if we didn't spend about 10 minutes
trying to pull fran out of a well later
on in the episode
and to me that shouldn't have had the
focus it did at the expense of these
other things
we also don't learn about the pastor joe
and for people who haven't read the book
i don't know how you wouldn't have major
question marks over what most of these
scenes meant
i easily could have watched three
seasons of a bug adaptation in which
they took their time and gave us reasons
to be attached to the characters
rather than simply skipping over the
relationships in order to take the story
beats off
now it's not too long before the pair
arrive in lawton nebraska
aka the home of mother abigail in the
book her parents were slaves in south
carolina
who relocated to hemingford home after
the civil war
i feel like this is important to bear in
mind as the child version of the
character does pop up later on at this
location
which is actually packed with stephen
king easter eggs
upon entering it we can see a statue of
a turtle which is likely a nod to mature
in
the well in which franny falls down is
also very similar to the one in 1922
which i definitely recommend you watch
if you haven't seen it
this story also took place at hemingford
home and heavily featured rats
one of which scares franny now another
notable easter egg there
is the tall grass which surrounds the
property in the king buck in the tall
grass
we saw as a group of people became lost
in some and the storyline dealt with
time loops
alternate versions of characters and how
one could travel back to the past
and forward to the future i think the
understanding of these little details is
paramount to getting what's going on in
the scenes that play out
and the way that i look at them is that
the past version of abigail
managed to travel to the future to save
franny the main indicator of this
is the silver cross necklace which is
also been present on mother abigail
throughout the season
i have read that this could be
interpreted as the baby abigail coming
back to save her mother
but she sings the same song that old
abigail sings later on the porch
meaning that that's pretty unlikely long
grasses also appear throughout the
season as a symbol of abigail so the
clues are all there and
it is quite well pointed out on a second
viewing now depending on what version
you check out the ghost of abigail did
actually appear in the story to look
over the baby in the nursery
and she remarked on her name but this
isn't carried over to this depiction
instead what we get is flag making
franny fall and she comes face to face
with him gleefully watching over a tribe
that are untouched by trips
the other character said throughout the
season that he wanted to liberate people
we learned that he just wants to be
worshipped and thus he can start his own
civilization
under the name russell faraday i'll talk
more about what this means later on
but fran's journey here is very similar
to jesus's in the desert
when he was tempted by the devil did i
say jesus this is right there
i don't know anyway this is murdered by
abigail's trek through the forest which
happened earlier in the season
and during that flag said that he was
legion similar the words uttered by the
demon that tried to tempt jesus
he sees that stew is potentially going
to get crushed by his truck
and that fran could die in the well
leading to the baby abigail dying too
all flag wants is a kiss and to be able
to see things through her eyes from time
to time
but she bites down on his lip and is
then transported to the tall grass once
more which is where she meets an older
abigail
abigail tells her that flag is still
trying to control others through fear
but the fact that fran stood up to him
means that she will be blessed by god
fran could die however she's rescued by
stew
and a younger abigail who then heals her
bringing forth this blessing
now one of the interesting things that
abigail states is that fran will be the
mother of five who will go on to have 20
children who will then go on to have 70
which you will live to see
these will replenish the earth and this
fran and stew should very much be seen
as adam and eve
the pair left paradise to go into the
harsh unknown but they will find a way
i i just hope those kids aren't making
kids with their brothers and sisters
anyway
after abigail tells her to stand hey we
get a one week time jump
in which the pair arrive at franny's
birthplace and she lays out how she's
following the advice that
abigail and god gave her this means that
the world will be repopulated
and she will tell the children to be
true and thus humanity has some hope
as mentioned earlier there is very much
a motif of rebirth
and thus everything is coming full
circle which also just happens to be the
the title of this episode very subtle
elsewhere we could the flag in his boots
arriving in front of the tribe
they bow down to worship him after he
kills one of their members
showing that he is once more ruling
through fear
this highlights that there will always
be good and evil in the world
and that some will lord over others and
make them fall in line
whilst others will show leadership
through hope now at the moment there are
no plans to carry on the show with the
second season
and i really doubt that we'll be getting
one due to the general reaction
to to what cbs have done however if
you're curious to know what happens next
with flag
then you should check out the dark tower
which takes place after captain trips
in that he goes under many names and
it's safe to assume that these islanders
actually helped him to ascend to being
an all-powerful god once more
the details of his life are sketchy and
there are a lot of blanks
but that's personally how i've always
taken the events to progress
now as for the series as a whole i
started off really liking this
but it became a chore to get through as
soon as we got to vegas
i felt like the series had a lot of
issues tonally and then it got
worse the longer that it went on now i
don't just want to slam the show
so we'll talk about the good even though
it's a bit difficult
i think bought ezra miller that the
actors did a really good job with what
they had
owen teague who played harold was very
very good
and he and brad williams hank as tom
cullen really stood out as the best
performances to me
marsden has always nailed the
down-to-earth middle american guy
and skarsgard as flag 2 was very
menacing
i could go on complimenting all the
actors and bar ezzy there's not really
someone who i can point to that i think
handled the material badly
now whilst i think the cast worked
really well it's just
what they were given was so compressed
that it's difficult to really become
attached to the characters properly
because of a lot of things including
their deaths happening so fast
as i mentioned earlier i would have
loved to have spent a lot of time with
these characters over seasons and
seasons
but because of the pacing people are
gone before you really get to know them
there's also a lot of things from the
book omitted which one can understand in
an adaptation
but some elements get focused that
definitely don't deserve it
at the expense of others overall it just
feels like a missed opportunity
and i know that's a very cliched thing
to say
but it's the the only way to describe it
that i think feels fitting
the production values were definitely
there as was the cast
it's just the way that the story was
told that really let things down
but these directors editors cast members
and so on with a really good script that
takes its time
and you could have had something special
but i just feel like it lacks
i'd understand something that i'm going
to return to and in all honesty
i do feel like the 90s mini series was a
lot better
sure it hasn't aged that well but in my
opinion it just feels like more
enjoyable watch
so if you still have questions over this
series then yeah give give that a chance
however removing the book the mini
series and judging this on its own merit
unfortunately in my opinion it scores a
5 out of 10.
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the series as a whole and of course
it's ending
if you enjoyed our coverage on it then
i'd really appreciate the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for videos
like this each and every week
don't forget that on the 28th of
february we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3mcu 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
one division which will be linked on
screen right now
we've been going over the whole series
week by week and giving our theories
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace